the dak Prescott situation continues to
percolate and I had access to Steven
Jones the Cowboys CEO Oh executive vice
president and director of player
personnel on Friday afternoon we spoke
for about 20 minutes and I was trying to
come up with ways to just kind of get at
how they are dealing with this challenge
of getting dak Prescott sod when we
consider Chris the fact that that
prescott currently has the franchise tag
@ 31.4 million for this year and by rule
next year it becomes thirty seven point
six eight million and by rule the year
after that if they wanted to take him a
third time it goes up forty four percent
and it will be north of fifty four
million how are they gonna handle this
how are they gonna do it and you know
it's a deadline driven business and one
of the things I asked Stephen Jones is
whether we should be focusing on July 15
that's when the window closes for doing
a long term deal with a player who has
the franchise tag here's Stephen Jones
regarding the deadline for getting it
done with DAC I mean at the end of the
day I know everybody's out there you
know how have you not paid back you know
at the same time that cast it we've
tried to pay him and he has to accept
what we want to pay him but the deals
got to be right for Doc he's got to be
right for us as you know Mike the salary
cap makes this a zero-sum game for
owners this is not something where Jerry
and myself are trying to save money so
the Cowboys can make more money for the
Jones family we're we're just trying to
do our very best working with my work
and with Wilma clay - really / - win a
Super Bowl you know there's all sorts of
analytics out there that show if your
quarterback takes up to bigger
percentage of your salary cap that you
know it decreases your chances to walk
and so just trying to figure out the
right fit no one wants to sign back to a
longer term deal look more than Jerry
and myself we're on the record time and
time again on what we think in him as a
leader he has the it factor he's a
fierce competitor he wants to win as
well and it's just got to be right for
him and right for us we'll continue to
work to a conclusion on that
all sounds good all makes sense but the
reality is Chris dak has the leverage
he's got the thirty-one point four
million in hand he's got the promise of
thirty seven point six eight million
next year whatever the Cowboys offer him
has to make deck willing to trade in
what he currently has that it's a simple
bargain it's like buying someone's car
right how much you want for the car well
I'll just keep the car what dad can keep
is thirty one for thirty seven six eight
and then in 2022 an opportunity to say
I'm hitting the open market with sixty
nine million plus in his pocket it's not
gonna be easy to get the Cowboys to a
point where dak says I'll trade in what
I already have for whatever it is you
want to pay me well yeah but you don't
have that you know so that to me is it
the balance there and you know I'm case
in point in this conversation anyway
it's sure those numbers sound great and
you know that's a lot of in factor there
well what if what if and my if factors
he tears his Nia or something like that
and now he's not making at that blame
okay hang on hang on
he's never missed a game he's got
insurance up and or out the wazoo and
he's got plenty of marketing money
he's been playing year-to-year his
entire career because the Cowboys have
made him play year to year especially
last year when they could have signed
him for a hell of a lot less than what
it's gonna cost now it's very easy for
Doc Prescott to say I'm gonna do what
Kirk Cousins did 31.5 thirty-one point
four million is guaranteed for this year
all he's got to do is make it through
this year he's getting thirty seven
point six eight movie next Jets not a
whole lot of ifs Christopher Oh doc
that's all you got to do doc just play
sixteen games with people trying to kill
you every game and you just that's all
you gotta do just be healthy you'll be
okay
he's played before Tom Brady never got
hurt until he got hurt and then he
missed the whole season during a year
but he loses you know Lucas is a big
part of this contractor is leverage
because of his health so I mean I
understand what you're saying and you're
I'm just giving you a hard time of
course but I will say to you know that
yes there has to be that risk factor
there but the
biggest thing with dak Prescott - and
and the Dallas Cowboys and I really
believe the Dallas Cowboys want to get
this deal done and Mike I've done some
digging on this little a little bit to
where I feel like I got a pretty good
feel and you know from from everything I
know or hear about the subject it really
seems to come down to a fourth and a
fifth year as far as the contract
extension is concerned and from what
I've been told
I mean dak Prescott just like Steven
Jones said I will echo this has been
offered an unbelievable contract you
know I've been told it was thirty five
million dollars a year on average so
they're trying to make him the
highest-paid quarterback in football the
big thing is is I guess guaranteed money
and the thing that I've been told more
than anything is the fifth-year dak
Prescott in his agent don't want a
fifth-year they want a fourth year on
the contract the Cowboys want that fifth
year and because the Cowboys want that
fifth year dak and his company sound let
our camp sound like they're willing to
go there but only if it's like a number
that protects them for what the
quarterback number might be five six
years from now which I understand and
they want a number on that last year
that I've been told is around forty five
forty six million dollars and I think
that's where the disconnect is right now
and that's where the Jones and dak
Prescott and I have to get together and
talk this out a little bit and try to
figure it out because I'm just shocked
we're still sitting here and this has
not been resolved if only they would
just guarantee that he receive a set
percentage of the salary cap five years
from now if only someone would ever
steal my idea and it's really not my
idea it's an idea that I stole from
others who have tried to get a
percentage of the salary cap in lieu of
a set number because that's the problem
as the cap grows and grows now we're in
the middle of a pandemic that may take a
significant chunk out of the NFL's
revenue streams by the time this season
ends which would affect next year's cap
but conceptually and barring a pandemic
the salary cap keeps going up and up and
up and the problem is you lock into a
five-year deal where as of right now the
fifth year salary seems fair but when we
get
year five the market has changed
dramatically and doc Prescott's looking
at what he's making saying what the
hell's wrong with this picture that's
why I've been a proponent of
guaranteeing that a key quarterback of
Patrick Mohammed AK Prescott a Cuyler
Maria Lamar Jackson the list is going to
go on and on as these great young
quarterbacks get to the point where they
are do new contracts just give them a
percentage of the salary cap whatever
the cap may be then you have the
remaining percentage left over to pay
the rest of your players it's simple
it's fair and that's the way to get that
Prescott I believe to agree to a fifth
year you don't even have to do it here's
one two three and four just do it year
five just guarantee his salary will be X
or X percent of the salary cap whichever
is greater
it's that simple yeah well I mean I hear
you it makes a lot of sense you know it
does it really does now let me ask you
this bike and a year like this if you're
a player do you run it I mean okay when
it comes to just a last year of the
contract and percentage thing that might
work but right now if you were dak
Prescott and you were looking for a
percentage of the team salary cap do you
want it right now because of what you
said I mean what if the pandemic and
everything that happens this year leads
the next year salary cap to go down
twenty million dollars or fifteen or
thirty million dollars whatever it may
be
all the sudden his percentage rethinks
okay this is going to be great he's
gonna get a low number to where he'll be
back down you know below Matt Ryan or
Ryan Tannehill as far as average and per
money or average per year so what do you
think there I'm just asking you in
curiosity it's a simple answer
look Cowboys you waited until after the
pandemic to get serious about this if
you'd sign me last year and we had
talked percentage of the salary cap you
don't one that bargain because you'd be
paying me less in 2021 if the cap goes
down now folks here's what I got thirty
one for this year and by rule a twenty
percent raise next to you regardless of
what happens with the salary cap I'm
looking at thirty seven point six eight
million next year so if the cap plummets
to one hundred and fifty million who
thirty seven point six eight million is
a hell of a lot
greater percentage of the salary cap for
your quarterback than you ever bargained
for
I got leverage give me what I want I
mean that's the bottom line here that's
what we can't get away from and Chris I
know that I remember you interviewing
dak Prescott at the Super Bowl in
Atlanta sitting on his Sleep Number bed
talking about doing a team friendly deal
and he gave you the side I remember that
look yeah if he was ever gonna do a team
friendly deal he would have done it by
now
he has taken a businesslike approach to
this every step of the way
it has vexed and frustrated and
confounded the Cowboys and there's no
reason to think he's gonna stop now and
here's what's amazing here's here's what
surprised me more than anything else
because I tried to attack the problem
different ways like hey Steven after
July 15
you know how comfortable are you if dak
holds out and Andy Dalton is that this
is the starter and training camp in the
preseason is that one of the reasons why
he didn't want to talk about anything
other than signing tacked to a long-term
deal period well I said how about this
how about this is there any chance that
the Cowboys exercised the nuclear option
of rescinding the franchise tag taking
away the 31 for and making dak Prescott
a free agent now at a time when no one
else is gonna pay him 31 for or anything
close to it the depth charts are set the
budgets are blown I asked even Jones is
there a chance that franchise tag will
be rescinded here's what he had to say
that's our quarterback for the future
obviously this it hadn't been the
easiest thing as Jerry says as money
gets bigger deals get harder certainly
we're talking you know a significant
amount of money here which he so
deserves but absolutely not that's going
to be our quarterback this year he's our
quarterback for the future we think the
world of him he represents our franchise
in a very positive way in terms of what
we want as a leader of our team and he's
just an outstanding man we would never
send the franchise tag bottom line there
it goes the nuclear option will remain
under wraps Chris I was surprised that
that they didn't at least say we'll
cross that bridge when we come to it or
so
chances can change in August let's just
say absolutely not will not rescind the
franchise tag now that doesn't operate
as a legal waiver of their ability to
rescind the franchise tag and if they
decide to do it all they have to do is
deal with the fact that Stephen Jones
said they wouldn't in May and it's very
easy to say things change but I was
surprised that he was that forceful that
they're not going to do it at least you
want to keep that option on the table
because that's the only leverage you
have at this point if you're the Cowboys
well yeah I mean it is certainly one of
the only leverage tools they have I get
that but at the same time it's very
dangerous for a team that we know is you
know in that Super Bowl window or on
paper has a Super Bowl talent you know
on their roster so they don't want to
they don't want to dance with that or
dangle with that danger of that you know
it's different than what we saw from
Josh Norman a few years ago when the
Carolina Panthers rescinded a Dave
gentlemen and company and he went to the
Washington Redskins you know first off
it's not a quarterback Josh Norman
you know love/hate whatever relationship
in the locker room whatever it may be
dak Prescott there's none of that he's
the leader of the football team they
love them they've already talked about
that they make that well well-known and
I think the team feels very similar
about dak Prescott is what we hear the
Jones family say too so when you do that
that will open up eyes if you were
rescinded the franchise tag on a guy
like dak Prescott where the other 52
guys on the team go man
nobody really stays in the facility
longer on a daily basis than dak
Prescott nobody does the little things
to make this team better and more often
the dak Prescott yeah the Cowboys will
lose respect within the locker room and
they'll have a few issues there that can
cause dysfunction so that's where you
got to be careful but I also want to sit
here to dak Prescott mic and go you know
I just I don't know if I agree with some
of the demands I'm hearing and again I
don't know if I've heard everything a
hundred percent I'd love to talk to dak
Prescott and know exactly what's
bothering him from his side breakfast
from the thing I've get from multiple
people around the league is it comes
down to that fifth year and to me at
some point dak Prescott just gotta go
listen they're paying you to be the
highest-paid player in the his
a football they're paying you to put you
know paying you more than guys who
deserve to be paid more than you you
know doc Prescott again I don't think
he's one of the five best quarterbacks
is he somewhere six through ten
definitely he hasn't won up he's won one
playoff game right you know he's gonna
be making more money than guys that were
in his draft clap that went to a Super
Bowl and Carson Wentz who you know
should have won an MVP and has been to
playoff games too so there's got to be a
little give-and-take I guess is what I'm
saying it sounds like to me it's more
dak that's got to give a little bit than
the Cowboys but Kris here's the thing
the market no longer matters once you're
into the franchise tag calculation
that's what people are losing sight of
it doesn't matter what Carson Wentz or
Russell Wilson or Aaron Rodgers or
anyone else is making what matters is
thirty-one point four million this year
37 point six eight million next year the
threat / promise of dak Prescott forcing
his way to the open market after only
two seasons like Kirk Cousins did
because they don't want to pay him fifty
four point two five million in 2022
that's what's driving this it doesn't
matter what the market is and let me
give you a contrast here and it's
surprising that of the two teams the
Cowboys and your New York Giants the
Cowboys are being far less shrewd than
the Giants were and here's a quick
example and we're gonna take a break
soon but when Eli Manning was entering
the final year of his prior contract the
one before the one that just ended when
you looked at what his franchise tag
number was going to be the following
year based upon what his cap number was
entering the last year of his contract
when you looked at what that franchise
tag number was going to be and you
started running the numbers based on the
franchise tag analysis his contract
would have made him the highest-paid
quarterback in football at the time in
large part because the market had
stagnated around twenty to twenty two
and a half million with Joe Flacco and
Aaron Rodgers so what happened was when
Eli Manning starts putting numbers on
the table via his agency the same agency
that represents dak somebody from the
Giants started leaking to the media that
Eli Manning wants to be the highest-paid
player in football there was a backlash
against Eli and abracadabra
Eli takes a hell of a lot less than his
leverage would
allowed him to take the Giants won that
by taking him on from a PR standpoint
and there was nothing Eli could do about
it
the Cowboys need to be willing to do
something like that Chris if they're
gonna win this thing with dak well yeah
I mean I guess so yes it seems like it's
going that way you know because I will
say I mean just from sitting here and
you know Mike I'm never really on the
team side of this stuff just from the
outside looking in it seems like the
team has really tried to be very
supportive of that Prescott and of
course giving them great contract offers
you know and again I you know all right
I know we're always about maximizing
money but if he gets thirty five million
dollars a year that's seventy million in
two years that beats that 68 you know
the the the 69 oh it beats it by 1
million straight it's the story how much
of its fully guaranteed at signing how
much what is the cash flow that's the
thing you can say we're offering you a
five-year deal that's worth thirty five
million a year but if there's you know
it's there's there's lots of ways to
fudge those numbers to make it look
better than it really is I hear what
you're saying but here's the key and
here's the lesson for every other team
out there the Dallas Cowboys case study
when you have a quarterback especially a
mid to late round quarterback who's on a
four-year contract and he becomes your
starter right out of the gates I mean
we've never seen this before where a guy
becomes the starter as a rookie week one
as a fourth round pick and starts every
game for four years here's the thing
after that third regular season ends and
the window opens for a long-term deal do
it then put a money offer in front of
the guy that he can't say no to and the
time to do what that Chris would have
been this because after his third season
they made it to the postseason you're
allowed to sign him to a new contract as
soon as the regular season ends not when
the playoffs end and there's a lot of
people who have high-paying jobs in the
NFL who don't realize this it's when the
regular season ends you go to a guy as
he's staring down a playoff run you make
him an offer that he can't refuse that's
a hell of a lot less than 35 million a
year they'd have had this done last
January I hear that
I'm not disagreeing with you there one
bit I think that's one this is one spot
where the Jones family messed up
business-wise where you went you know
this is your guy he had taken to the
playoffs twice at that point two into
the first three years and Zeke Elliott
was you know had a bunch of issues in
year two and that's why they didn't end
up making the playoffs and kind of fell
off that year but you're right that was
the time to strike they could have
probably got dak Prescott for 27 28
million dollars a year at that point and
he would have been happy to take it sign
the deal let's go let's move on but he
played really well last year he is one
of the better quarterbacks in football
and he does have great leverage over the
cowboy franchise right now because of
all the things you mentioned so I just I
guess like I said I'm just surprised
we're still sitting here and this hasn't
got done I still think it will because I
think dak Prescott loves the Cowboys and
as a professional and wants to be the
starting quarterback at all those types
of things but they're gonna have to meet
somewhere in the middle here with some
of their disagreements July 15 is the
target when the Cowboys signed dez
bryant to a long-term deal from under
the franchise tag July 15 was the day
they got it done at deadlines drive
action in the NFL and Stephen Jones made
it clear that is the date we are
watching and it's just about two months
away alright we need to take a quick
break
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports